hi I'm manda Molina I am been hi my name
is Michael I'm Jenna and today we are
going to compare Swedish meatballs and
Italian meatballs I don't actually know
if I how to tell you meatballs I have
not had Swedish food before give
everything out there's a lot of weird
stuff that we mean but we have
everything from rotten fish to the
meatballs tomato sauce doesn't go hand
in hand but I mean is probably delicious
so we'll see I have had Swedish
meatballs from Ikea but I don't know if
those are legit or not I actually really
love and amiibos from Ikea so I don't
blame you they're really really
delicious they're not really the
meatballs that my mom would make you
know in but they are really good okay
okay wait what is this I thought I
thought they're supposed to be like
gravy and stuff on this this is like the
Swedish meatball sandwich but we kind of
call it shift boot lip again at least
that's what I say where I'm from it was
like pink stuff yes it's a pink the pink
stuff the the red beet salad so we have
beet salad okay made of beets meatballs
so this is a dried onion no roasted
onion lettuce but they kind of put it in
a hot dog bun I think what is it usually
served in a but get is this like a
meatball sandwich it is like a meatball
sub I'm not a picky here but there's
something something about this
cheers Cheers
oh [ __ ] mmm
oh yeah it's really good especially with
the beets mm-hmm
Ike the beets mm-hmm I didn't think I
was going to like them but look you're
not supposed to eat it with a fork look
at out you know yeah a big bite out of
it I feel like the meatballs a Sweden
are smaller yeah these are big ones but
this one though the beet salad I mean
the meat part is like relatively similar
but the sauce and Italian meatballs
makes it a whole nother level it tastes
like it's missing like some key Italian
herbs and spices
you know the oregano and the fennel
I'm gonna have to say we win oh we
haven't tried yours yeah yeah but I
already know this Swedish meatball
sandwich I didn't even know they existed
I'm here forever I like it
oh yeah they're smaller tonight and then
I thought they would be
well authentic Italian meatballs are
actually quite small everything American
meatballs are the other giant ones
obviously they're actually called
Polpette day in Italy you know I don't
think I've ever ordered this ever ever
you know like twirl the floor get a
little spaghetti in there that's what
I'm talking about you ready let's do it
they have like parmesan exactly you're
adding things now aren't you
it's an affair take the other
I like this better
I can't believe I said that I feel like
it has more more flavor I mean the the
pasta and the sauce really helps
bringing moisture
it's a weird combination for me to eat
meatballs with marinara sauce I know it
sounds like so of course you do that
right but we don't in Sweden so it's
still a little weird
they're definitely a little more easy to
chew they're not if you don't feel as
dense Estes we just want to it's got
some I'll get some you know what I'll
say is that I think the Swedish
meatballs stand alone really held their
own I'd say like this because it has
like the tomato sauce and the pasta all
of it together it's just like ma perfect
you know in this particular round I
think in the Italian ones win I'll give
it to you thank you so I need
[Music]